on va parler de la loi de programmation
militaire évidemment avec vous messieurs
d'abord on le disait Marion les
sénateurs ont entamé et hier l'examen de
cette loi de programmation militaire
alors qu'elles ont été les temps forts
de cette première heure de séances que
vous allez suivez alors un an que ce
texte était en préparation et comme
évoqué en introduction par le ministre
des Armées Sébastien Lecornu il répond à
un constat les menaces qui pèse sur la
France n'ont jamais été aussi diverses
protéiformes que depuis la fin de la
guerre froide à terrorisme
militarisation de l'espace des fonds
marins du cyber mais aussi et surtout
l'agression russe en Ukraine qui a
rebattu les cartes en Europe et dans le
monde et c'est donc pour cette raison
qu'une nouvelle loi de programmation
militaire était nécessaire et je vous
propose d'écouter à ce sujet justement
le ministre des Armées hier
c'est toi de programmation militaire
doit permettre non seulement de
poursuivre une réparation d'un outil de
défense et là s'abîmer dans le passé par
des politiques parfois courtermiste et
une forme de déni il faut le reconnaître
sur la réalité du monde mais aussi de
transformer nos forces sur des fonctions
militaires concrètes avec des objectifs
opérationnels précis et cette
transformation elle passe donc par une
hausse du budget de la défense de 40%
par rapport à la période actuelle pour
atteindre sur les 7 années de ce
programme d'ici à 2030 un montant de
413,3 milliards d'euros et sur les
nombreux objectifs en matière de défense
Mario et consensus on trouve
gouvernement et majorité sénatori alors
oui il y a consensus sur les enjeux
mémoires sur la méthodologie et le
calendrier les sénateurs estiment que le
gouvernement reporte à l'après 2027
l'essentiel des dépenses pour Christian
Cambon c'est le rapporteur de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées il faut au
contraire passer la vitesse supérieure
faire en sorte que les crédits qui sont
plus prévus soit mobilisés dès l'année
prochaine pour financer l'activité des
forces leur entraînement mais aussi les
stocks et l'entretien du matériel alors
ça c'est pour la droite un autre son
cloche évidemment du côté de la gauche
côté notamment communiste Pierre Laurent
défendu une notion de rejet du texte oui
émotion qui a été qui n'a pas été retenu
le groupe communiste qui dénonce dans
cette loi de programmation un suarmement
qui nourrit la guerre et je vous propose
on nous dit que la peine est plus une
option qu'il faut fondre place dans la
grande dérive militariste mondiale c'est
oublier toutes les leçons du XXe siècle
la militarisation et le suarmement
singulièrement en Europe ont toujours
préparé la guerre et bien pire encore
jamais la paix
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à cette
intention Pierre Laurent
on peut considérer qu'il n'y a pas tort
la difficulté c'est que on est dans un
monde
multipolaire dans un monde de plus en
plus compliqué et où il est courant de
dire que tout le même que si vous voulez
la paix il faut préparer la guerre et
qu'un moment donné pour pouvoir exister
pour pouvoir peser pour pouvoir
dissuader un potentiel adversaire il
faut pouvoir lui expliquer que si
toutefois il devait avoir
la malencontreuse envie de nous attaquer
et bien il en subirait les conséquences
le monde des bisounours il existe mais
juste à la télévision malheureusement
est-ce que ce texte il répond aux
menaces qui pèsent aujourd'hui sur la
France puisque Marion le rappelait c'est
l'enjeu de ce texte rappelé par
Sébastien Lecornu un des grands
reproches que nous faisons à ce texte
c'est sûr c'est essentiellement de ne
pas définir très clairement la stratégie
vers laquelle vous nous emmener le
ministre des Armées
le dernier revenu national stratégique
qui a été définie l'année dernière par
le Président de la République ne dit
rien sur la stratégie qu'on veut mettre
en oeuvre en dehors de la seule j'allais
dire nouvelle chose c'est l'influence
c'est à dire qu'il parle beaucoup
d'influence et de la nécessité de lutter
contre cette influence contre contre ce
que nous
visualisons visualisons pardon les uns
et les autres dans ce monde qui de plus
en plus est soumis à des fake news une
lutte d'informationnelle etc donc ça
c'est un sujet qui est abordé dans la
revue nationale stratégique mais rien
d'autre et donc les reproches que nous
faisons aujourd'hui au gouvernement
c'est celui-là c'est celui de ne pas
nous expliquer vers quoi il veut aller
quel est le but de cette loi de
au sujet et vous êtes tombé exactement
dans le panneau c'est celui de
il y a 413 milliards d'euros dans cette
loi de programmation militaire nous
avons expliqué pendant nous n'avions pas
la même conception
Mont-de-Marsan le 20 janvier dernier le
budget des armées puisqu'il a expliqué
qu'il y avait 400 milliards d'euros plus
13,3 milliards d'euros ne pas dès le
départ expliquer qu'il y a 413 milliards
d'euros tout simplement parce que les
13,3 milliards d'euros qui viennent en
plus des 400 milliards sont des
critiques qui sont des crédits extra
budgétaires et qui pour l'essentiel
d'entre eux pour 7,4 milliards d'Europe
ne sont pas renseignés n'existe pas et
donc ce qu'a voulu faire le Sénat avec
cet article 3 hier c'est sacralisé c'est
13,3 milliards d'euros pour qu'on soit
certains qu'à l'issue de la loi de
programmation militaire et bien il soit
mis à disposition de nos armées en plus
des 400 milliards et le gouvernement a
tellement communiqué sur ce sujet depuis
janvier en expliquant que ce sera 413 et
pas 400 qu'il s'est emmêlé les pinceaux
dans son propre tapis et aujourd'hui on
se retrouve à le mettre de vente de ces
de ces contradictions
du budget écoutez le budget les
problèmes de finances c'est un sujet qui
intéresse en fait l'ensemble des
finances publiques donc
400 413 je vais pas rentrer dans ce
débat là qui est pas mon débat moi de
militaire même si c'est un budget alors
que à 400 ou 413 est-ce que c'est un
budget qui est à la hauteur pour
redonner des moyens à l'armée alors il
est il est à la hauteur si vous le
comprenez complètement en prenant les
deux lois de programmation doublement du
budget on peut pas dire que c'est
n'importe quoi
ça fait ça fait écho si vous voulez à
j'allais dire presque la désespérance
des armées dans les années précédentes
où c'était un démontage systématique et
moi je rends grâce au chef d'état-major
aux militaires que j'ai contacté que
j'ai connu et sous lesquels j'ai servi
qui pendant toutes ces années ont essayé
de sauvegarder ce qui pouvait être
sauvegardé c'est pour on a eu une armée
échantillonnaire et c'est pour ça qu'on
a une capacité de remonter en puissance
alors est-ce qu'il y en a assez est-ce
que je laisse vraiment les élus discuter
sur ce sujet de finance moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que cette loi de
programmation à trois aspects
extrêmement intéressants d'abord la
dissuasion et ceux qui protègent la
France il faut le rappeler c'est le
premier point deuxièmement la France
n'est pas l'Ukraine c'est-à-dire que la
France a son rôle à jouer dans l'OTAN et
dans l'Union européenne mais elle n'est
pas l'Ukraine permettait à quelqu'un qui
vient des Nations Unies de rappeler que
la France est globale et que quand aux
Nations Unies on parle d'un dossier quel
qu'il soit la France est toujours
présente et le troisième sujet important
ce sont les nouveaux outils dont il faut
se doter je veux parler de l'espace du
cyber des drones qui sont des choses qui
sont arrivées depuis peu finalement sur
le théâtre et qui donc la France était
relativement mal équipé et dont elle
doit être des moyens
[Musique]
etc donc il est difficile effectivement
d'arriver à faire admettre que ce budget
est suffisant pour arriver à l'objectif
que nous étions que nous avions fixé en
2018 puisque les cibles que nous devions
atteindre en 2025 ne seront atteintes
qu'en 2035 et donc le défi aujourd'hui
du Sénat c'est de dire effectivement on
veut accélérer le financement pour que
chaque année il y ait davantage d'argent
que ce que aujourd'hui le ministre nous
propose propose 3 milliards
d'augmentation annuelle nous proposons
3,6 pour éviter qu'en 2027 nous n'ayons
cette bosse budgétaire cette
augmentation considérable du budget qui
fera que le prochain de la République
président de la République aura pour
première j'allais dire mission
d'augmenter le budget des armées de 1,3
milliards d'euros au lendemain de son
élection donc nous essayons de lisser
les choses dans le temps pour que compte
tenu de l'inflation également nous ayons
plus de capacités d'acquérir du matériel
aujourd'hui parce que un euro 2023 ne
voudra évidemment pas un euro de 2030 et
on pense que on a et c'est évidemment
important c'est ces questions
financières Cédric Perrin mais est-ce
que ce budget
permet à l'armée d'avoir les moyens de
fonctionner est-ce qu'aujourd'hui de
l'armée a les moyens matériels à les
moyens humains nécessaires la question
la question des moyens humains est
différente et je me souviens d'une
visite que j'ai fait dans les forces
océaniques stratégiques il y a très peu
de temps où on me disait
c'est bien d'augmenter la capacité en
matériel n'oubliez pas que derrière tout
ça il y a des hommes et des femmes et
que l'effectif il est évidemment capital
aujourd'hui il faut il faut être très
clair sur le fait que en 2030 les
effectifs de l'armée n'auront pas
augmenté par rapport à ce qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui on sera à 275000 on a
augmenté de 4 de l'ordre de 4000 la
difficulté pour les armées aujourd'hui
c'est de recruter cette année l'objectif
était à 1500 on a pu recruter 700 donc
il faut bien comprendre que la situation
dans laquelle est notre pays où les gens
n'ont plus envie de travailler
se traduit également dans l'armée où on
a des difficultés comme dans le reste de
la société à recruter pour des raisons X
et Y peut-être aussi le fait de la
guerre en Ukraine et qu'on se rend
compte qu'effectivement aujourd'hui le
métier de militaire et peut-être plus
celui qu'on faisait il y a 15 ou 20 ans
donc je je donne quelques exemples mais
il y en a sans doute beaucoup d'autres
et ça c'est un véritable sujet sur
lequel il faut travailler également la
fidélisation en capacité à conserver les
militaires une fois leur contrat terminé
et on va en parler générale trinquant
avant de vous entendre évidemment sur ce
sujet du recrutement et de la
fidélisation on va regarder notre
reportage puisque ce texte vise on le
disait à rendre l'armée plus attractive
comment attirer comment garder les gens
qui s'engagent chez l'une des
difficultés à laquelle est confrontée
l'armée aujourd'hui Jonathan du Priest
nous emmène voir comment justement la
remet tente de recruter
lissez voiloum à Aulnay-sous-Bois le
temps du matinée la Marine nationale
fait escalier si pour présenter ses
activités
certaines d'entre vous sont intéressés
par le fait de rentrer dans la marine il
faudra soit tellement passer par nous
pour capter l'attention des lycéens
mettent en avant leur expérience
opérationnelle et vente le meilleur
atout de la marine pour se vendre les
missions sur toutes les mers du globe
comment j'ai plutôt sur les narcopes en
Amérique du Sud et sur des missions
humanitaires du voyage mais aussi des
perspectives de carrière de formation et
des salaires attrayants après deux
heures de présentation certains s'y
voient déjà
expliqué plusieurs types de formation ce
qu'on pouvait faire après après le lycée
tu ne verrais bien faire ça dans les
bateaux explorer le monde et tout la
marine souffre pourtant d'un déficit de
notoriété l'institution redouble donc
d'efforts pour se faire connaître loin
des zones côtières la majorité des
jeunes et n'a pas idée conscience que
c'est l'armée et surtout une fois qu'ils
ont pris conscience de ça n'a pas
conscience que on peut proposer plein de
choses différentes comme on l'a dit
pendant l'intervention 80 spécialités
différentes donc 80 métiers
sur 40 000 militaires au total la Marine
nationale compte sur un renouvellement
de 10% de ses effectifs chaque année
pour 2023 4300 postes sont à pourvoir et
ses besoins sont amenés accroître avec
la nouvelle loi de programmation
militaire toutes ces capacités elles ne
peuvent avoir un réel intérêt que si on
est capable de les armer avec des jeunes
qui sont formés qualifiés et prêts à
rejoindre la marine si l'armée tente de
recruter massivement c'est aussi pour
pallier l'évaporation croissante d'une
part de ces troupes entre déficit de
reconnaissance et concurrence avec le
privé l'armée a constaté plus 6% de
départ entre 2019 et 2022 alain a quitté
l’institution après 12 ans en tant
qu'officier dans la cybersécurité un
militaire au métier très recherché mais
dont l’avance en restait conditionné à
la hiérarchie militaire en dépit de ses
compétences
dans des arbitrages dans des échanges
une finesse et galon qui revient il y a
pas de carrière lié à des expertises
c'est une barrière d'officier et donc
27 ans de service sinon comptez 2 à 3
ans de procédure au tribunal
administratif le parcours est dix
sont légitimes convient même la plupart
des rencontres une administratifs sont à
gagner le but du jeu est de mettre
pour épauler les personnels en litige
avec l'armée avec dans les dossiers des
profils récurrents
pour moi de thématiques soit elles sont
d'ordre professionnel c'est à dire que
le parcours devient heurté l'évolution
de carrière est à l'arrêt avec aussi
beaucoup beaucoup de revendications on
va dire d'ordre personnel
puisque on sait très bien que en dehors
des militaires durant les sous-officiers
les officiers sont soumis à beaucoup
beaucoup de mutations beaucoup de
changements professionnels
sans parfois avoir un dialogue avec leur
hiérarchie ce qui est aussi créé
beaucoup de difficultés en France
l'armée de terre est la plus touchée par
ce phénomène d'évaporation des troupes
en 2022 le taux de résiliation des
contrats avant la fin de la formation à
atteint 32% soit prêt d'un engagé sur
trois
c'est difficile d'attirer aujourd'hui
dans l'armée Jonathan disait il y a un
déficit d'image notamment alors de
notoriété le premier point c'est que
c'est une une tendance générale de tous
les pays occidentaux
la tendance de la Genèse et pas
forcément et je ne mets pas tout le
monde dans le même sac d'aller vers
l'effort et il est certain que quand
vous êtes militaire il y a un certain
nombre de contraintes donc le premier
point c'est d'attirer de faire rêver le
deuxième point c'est de maintenir
effectivement faut rentabiliser
quelqu'un qui passe trois ans
l'investissement n'est pas vraiment
rentable donc il faut passer plus de
temps donc cette tendance est récente
pour les armées françaises jusqu'à il y
a deux ans on disait on recrute bien
depuis peu de temps j'ai écouté le chef
d'état-major de l'armée terre puisqu'on
parlait de l'armée de terre disait bah
écoutez là on commence à avoir des
difficultés pourquoi à cause de ce que
j'expliquais c'est à dire il faut
d'abord faire rêver pour attirer et
ensuite tout de suite maintenir je je
alors il y a un sujet qui revient tout
le temps sur la table c'est l'affaire de
sentinelle et je sais que au Sénat on va
en parler
sentinelle et quelque chose qui était
nécessaire à un moment donné qu'on
continue à voir nécessaire parce que les
armées sont dans la nation certes mais
les tours de sang en tunnel ça fait pas
franchement rêver et donc là il y a
quelque chose probablement à voir alors
il y a les Jeux Olympiques qui arrivent
on va le voir il y aura un problème
voilà exactement mais je pense qu'il y a
quelque chose à voir et dans le nouveau
dispositif on parle beaucoup de
l'outre-mer et je vois que le chef
d'état-major de l'armée de terre par
exemple a fait le tour de l'outre-mer
l'outre-mer ça fait rêver un jeune
parisien qui on va dire vous allez aller
en Guyane vous allez aller à la Réunion
vous allez aller en Nouvelle-Calédonie
ça fait rêver donc il faut faire rêver
deuxième point il faut les maintenir en
position et là moi je l'ai vécu de près
puisque j'ai dissout un régiment il y a
longtemps certes mais je l'ai dit sous
et je peux vous dire que la direction
des ressources humaines est très très
attentif et il y a vraiment
armée doit aussi s'adapter
au desiderata des jeunes d'aujourd'hui
et pas seulement faire comme un amiral
américain qui s'occupe des DRH disait le
matin on doit commencer par faire son
lit et ben ça c'est quelque chose des
règles simples comme ça mais en rentrant
dans l'armée petit à petit on les
apprend et c'est très utile à mon avis
pour la suite pour la réserve bien sûr
parce que on va doubler la réserve donc
c'est important faut avoir des gens qui
tend l'armée se disent ben je veux être
réserviste mais aussi des jeunes qui se
disent l'armée c'est pas tout dans 15
ans je ferais autre chose mais j'aurais
un beau bagage pour
du matériel c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
ce que je dis par rapport au fait qu'on
diminue de 30%
et je pense que ça participe aussi au
manque d'attractivité et puis moi ce que
si j'ai un message à pas aux jeunes qui
pourraient nous écouter c'est que dans
l'armée ça a été dit très bien ni dans
le reportage dans l'armée il y a une
multitude de métiers et des métiers qui
sont on n'est pas que avec un fusil à
défiler effectivement dans les rues de
quelques communes pour faire en gros les
vitrines des magasins et attendre de
voir ce qui va se passer c'est
sentinelles c'est pas ça le métier de
militaire le métier de militaire c'est
une multitude de métier qui sont de la
filière technique à la filière
pratique si je puis dire enfin donc il y
a plein de choses que les gens peuvent
faire et derrière vous avez une
employabilité si je puis dire dans le
privé quand vous aurez fait quelques
contrats et le plus possible je l'espère
qui est très important donc je pense
qu'il y a vraiment un intérêt
aujourd'hui à réexpliquer davantage à
nos jeunes quels sont les métiers qu'on
font des passages assez assez et assez
limité mais c'est aussi une capacité
dans son profil plus tard et c'est aussi
un service qu'on rend à son pays donc il
y a le salaire mais il y a aussi la
compétence qu'on acquiert il y a toute
la technicité qu'on acquiert dans ce
dans ces métiers militaires vous allez
éviter le porte-avion Charles de Gaulle
tous ceux qui travaillent sur la filière
nucléaire par exemple sont des gens qui
sont hyper courus dans le civil voilà
donc il y a il faut expliquer à nos
jeunes que ce sont des métiers
importants et surtout des métiers qui
sont des métiers d'avenir et puis aussi
attirer les filles parce que là il y a
pas beaucoup de filles quand même dans
le reportage c'est aussi un enjeu non
mais bien sûr bien sûr mais je veux dire
qu'il y a une image encore très
masculine
pas tant que ça vous savez c'est 20% à
peu près aujourd'hui les femmes dans
l'armée donc je crois que là ça a
beaucoup évolué la jeunesse a beaucoup
évolué là-dessus je voulais simplement
souligner le bah tiens très bien on voit
les images du 12e Régiment de curacia
qui est près de l'IVAC qui j'irai voir
dans 10 jours il y a aussi
ces matériels donc avoir les matériels
mais pouvoir s'entraîner comprenez bien
qu'un équipage de chars s'il voit son
char tous les trois mois ça va forcément
lui poser un problème de morale donc il
y a toutes il y a toutes ces capacités
et il faut que les jeunes sachent que
servir leur pays pendant un temps ils
vont pas y passer toute leur vie mais
pendant un temps utile c'est extrêmement
important et il faut être prêt en
permanence donc s'entraîner et se
préparer comme vous le disiez monsieur
le sénateur il y a plein de métiers dans
l'armée et comme vous êtes tiroir de
chat avant de rentrer dans la vie civile
ou c'est pas très utile des tireurs de
chat vous allez apprendre un autre
métier et ça les
armées savent le faire non je veux un
exemple moi je suis allé avec avec le
premier régiment d'artillerie faire des
tirs de lance-roquette unitaire en
Roumanie il y a très peu de temps et
j'étais pour la petite anecdote j'étais
avec un commandant qui est original
depuis 12 ans et bien ce que maintenant
qui est venu avec nous Roumanie c'était
la première fois il est 12 ans depuis 12
ans région c'est la première fois qu'il
faisait des participait à un tir de les
rues à munition réelle ça démontre aussi
une vraie problématique c'est à dire
quand vous quand les jeunes s'engagent
quand des moins jeunes s'engagent dans
l'armée c'est pour participer à des à
des exercices pour faire des choses qui
sont des choses concrètes et je rejoins
en salle le général trinquant on peut
pas aujourd'hui vouloir attirer on
attire pas les mouches avec du vinaigre
voilà comme disait ma grand-mère un mot
parce que vous parlez de la revue
stratégique tout à l'heure ça a été un
objet
française à ses yeux cela aurait été
nécessaire notamment pour mieux définir
la place que la France veut prendre
militairement mais aussi dans l'OTAN et
je vous propose de l'écouter à ce sujet
moi je suis pour une grande part avec
mon groupe favorable elle est beaucoup
plus loin dans l'OTAN et je le dis être
dans le temps ce n'est pas réduire son
indépendance ce n'est pas réduire sa
capacité à agir ce n'est pas réduire sa
capacité à décider ce n'est pas mettre
en partage la dissuasion nucléaire bien
au contraire mais quand je vois les
Allemands qui ces derniers jours ont été
pilotes pour la question de la
protection sur le j'ai envie de dire le
la protection anti-missile vous voyez
bien c'est ce que devrait faire la
France et c'est dommage qu'on puisse pas
le faire dans un texte légitime général
t'inquant c'est aussi un débat ça à la
place de la France dans l'OTAN c'est une
tarte à la crème il se trouve que
j'étais officier plan avant les années
90 je rappelle qu'on était pas dans le
comment
compte tenu de ce qui se passe dans
l'est du continent l'OTAN est évidemment
en première ligne il n'est plus en mors
cérébrale et ceci les gens vous disent
c'est en compétition avec l'Union
européenne j'y crois absolument pas je
crois que ce renforcer dans le temps
c'est renforcer notre position en Europe
et dans la défense de l'Europe et que il
faut arrêter d'avoir une vision trop
exagonale en disant on va vous montrer
quelque chose de différent de l'OTAN non
les pays européens aujourd'hui ne mise
leur sécurité que sur l'OTAN mais que se
passera-t-il dans deux ou trois ans si
l'administration américaine change et
devient d'un seul coup à vous dire que
l'article 5 ça veut rien dire et bien
les Européens se renforceront auront la
capacité entre européen de mieux se
défendre donc je crois que vraiment la
place dans le temps n'est pas un sujet
pour la France elle est un sujet au sens
où qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans l'OTAN et
la question aujourd'hui c'est est-ce
qu'on est capable d'avoir une structure
de corps d'armée qui est quelque chose
qui est demandé prépare l'OTAN je pense
qu'avilius on en parlera et que la
France se prépare pour l'année 2030
autant que je me souvienne pour avoir ce
niveau de compétence
bien sûr qu'on a au niveau de compétence
important je crois que l'armée française
dans les différentes opérations qui est
la plus mener ces dernières années
notamment les opérations extérieures
étaient j'allais dire admirer envier par
l'ensemble de nos de nos alliés
notamment américains et britannique pour
sa capacité à faire des choses avec des
moyens je veux dire humains et matériels
qui ne sont pas forcément à la hauteur
de ce que font de ce qu'on nous alliés
donc ce côté là je voudrais évidemment
le dire
une faiblesse matérielle de l'armée
française
évidemment on se rend bien compte que
aujourd'hui donner du matériel à
l'Ukraine c'est très compliqué parce
qu'on en a pas quand on donne quelques
lance-roquettes unitaires on sait très
bien que les moyens français sont
limités puisqu'on en dispose de 13 sur
le papier et que il y en a encore moins
qui sont en fonctionnement donc en
donner trois c'est déjà
nous sommes un pays doté mais
par ailleurs est-ce que j'ai dit dans un
rapport récent au Sénat il faut pas que
la dissuasion nouvelle ligne Maginot
c'est-à-dire que évidemment la situation
nucléaire est importante c'est un atout
considérable mais ne
négligeons pas l'aspect conventionnel
parce que l'aspect convention est
important et nous devons justement être
un allié exemplaire de l'OTAN et pour
être un allié exemplaire de l'entor un
allié exemplaire de l'OTAN il faut que
nous ayons en face le matériel
susceptible de pouvoir être mis à
disposition de potentiels et
malheureusement on arrive à la fin de ce
débat merci messieurs vous restez avec
nous on va regarder ce qu'elle a une de
nos quotidiens régionaux tout au sujet
si ils sont en perte de vitesse
autre interrogation celle du Républicain
Lorrain qui là aussi se demande si c'est
solde vocation et permettre aux Français
de consommer à nouveau selon une étude
OpinionWay publiée dans Le Télégramme ce
matin 61% des Français déclarent qu'ils
seront plus attentifs à cette des soldes
cette année le budget moyen de dépenses
envisager étant de 182 euros ce qui est
globalement
identique à l'an passé Emmanuel Macron
pour lui sa visite à Marseille et les
titres régionaux y consacrent à nouveau
leur une la Provence parle du labo
marseillais pour évoquer l'école du
futur envisagé par le chef de l'État qui
sera testé à Marseille dans des
établissements qui donneront une place
plus grande à la culture aux langues et
à l'environnement la Marseillaise vous
l'avait dit tout à l'heure Oriane résume
cette visite par le titre suivant gros
chèque et beaux discours quand la
Dépêche du Midi décide elle de tester la
méthode Macron en matière d'emploi le
chef de l'État assure qu'il est facile
de trouver du travail sur le vieux port
de Marseille alors chiche et bilan de la
recherche de la journaliste qui s'est
présenté incognito 13 propositions
d'emplois dans l'hôtellerie restauration
et même scénario à Toulouse
sont 44 à
Corrèze en 1969 11 soldat avait été
exhumé et cette fois agi de retrouver à
les 36 autres dans le but de rendre les
corps aux familles allemandes les
fouilles ont commencé hier ces soldats
étaient membres de la Wehrmacht basé à
Tulle en Corrèze et l'un des résistants
témoignent dans ce journal on n'avait
pas les structures pour garder ses
prisonniers on pouvait pas faire
autrement que les tuer 10 secondes pour
parler piscine oui puisqu'il fait très
chaud du côté de Lyon et les piscines
manquent malheureusement à l'appel dans
la métropole lyonnaise le progrès fait
le point sur les établissements
disponibles alors que les élus viennent
de lancer une étude pour peut-être
demain se baigner dans le Rhône et la
Saône voilà ce sera issu merci Marion
merci beaucoup général trinquant d'avoir
été avec nous merci Cédric Perrin on
continue à bien sûr à parler de cette
loi de programmation militaire demain
pour voir revoir cette émission c'est
sur public sénat.fr prochain rendez-vous
à 18h sans public Thomas Hugh on se
retrouve demain
[Musique]